une rencontre entre des jeunes inc aux
coups de pédales contre les violences
conjugales est un projet mené par
l'association nantaise social sport et
performance il ya quelques mois sept
jeunes ont pris la route à vélo
direction montpellier en soutien aux
femmes victimes de violences pour cette
journée internationale de lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes un
documentaire retraçant le parcours de
ces jeunes mais aussi des témoignages a
été diffusé au centre culturel le
chaplin de mantes-la-jolie ont traversé
cette étape cette ville plus de 790 km
après le film documentaire de bas
c'était surtout pour c'était surtout
pour pour nous et de fil en aiguille on
s'est rendu compte que ça pourrait être
un états unis pédagogique super
intéressant un périple à vélo parfois
compliqué à réaliser mais avec un
objectif en tête pour les jeunes lutter
contre les violences conjugales ça peut
tout nous entendre en fait qu'on soit
petit ou grand dans le futur et voilà
c'est important de 6 sensibiliser
personnellement déjà pour éviter que ça
puisse arriver au sein de notre propre
foyer plus de 1600 euros ont été
récoltés grâce à une cagnotte litchi
pour le centre d'information sur les
droits des femmes et des familles des
yvelines cette journée a été co piloté
par la ville et le commissariat de
mantes la jolie on a mobilisé les
acteurs qu'on connaît les partenaires de
terrain star et nice et des partenaires
essentiellement lequel je travaille au
quotidien au commissariat qui y viennent
s'exprimer la diffusion du documentaire
a été suivie de tables rondes des
intervenants et des professionnels de
terrain qui jalonnent le parcours d'une
victime on va présenter en fait tous les
maillons de la chaîne puis du début
quand on parle à son ami bah voila mon
mari m'a frappé c'est un problème et
puis en fait comment faire les
initiations aux gestes de défense et des
débats autour de cette problématique
sont prévus jusqu'au 2 décembre la jolie